hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
this morning droppin new flash costumes
bold new timelines bold new colors of
red so let's break it down
so everybody's looking at this and
saying hey wait a minute this is like
super bright like either somebody derped
in Photoshop and they cranked the
vibrance way up or this is an indicator
of Barry getting a more comic-book
accurate costume the bright apple red
flash costume instead of the dole red
one that he started out with in the
first season here we're gonna be talking
about this a little bit so I'm gonna
play this clip from the end of season 1
just for context so pay attention to
this because we'll be talking about all
the stuff happening in this moment
[Music]
so remember back to the season 1 finale
that's really like the beginning in the
end point of flashpoint so they've said
that flash points only gonna last a
couple episodes so you know whatever
ends up happening the changes they make
to the suit will happen in that time but
you have season 1 Barry with the red
flash emblem going back in time to save
his mother when he gets there he
encounters two separate versions of
himself from different periods in time
so the first version he encounters was
the original timeline Barry the one who
came back to prevent the reverse flash
from killing his younger self that's why
the reverse flash killed his mother
because he couldn't kill younger Barry
that was his original mission so he
decided out of spite to kill his mother
well if I can't have you I'll kill your
mother
I'll do whatever I can to rub salt in
the wound prevent you from being happy
so that was the beginning of season one
of the flash like we're already starting
out in a different timeline during the
first season we learned through
flashbacks periodically
that Barry became the flash but it
happened much later in his life like it
happened five or six years later I think
so the reverse flash came back tried to
kill his younger self Barry saves him
they set off the new timeline and then
the reverse flash gets stuck and he's
like okay I know the particle
accelerator goes off but I need that to
happen faster because I want to go home
I don't want to be stuck here so he
speeds up Barry becoming the flash and
you arrive at red emblem flash suit but
in the season 1 finale Barry goes back
to save his mother and as they saw the
other flash fighting with the reverse
flash when all of a sudden another
version of Barry gives him like the stop
don't do it this is like a very cool
interpretation of this flash cover just
like Barry Allen holding his hand out
stop dead in your tracks don't do what
you're getting ready to do so he listens
his mother still ends up dying it's
really horrifying for him to have to
watch that and he says his last goodbyes
as she dies and then the other versions
of the flash all disappear and he goes
back to the future so when he's talking
to Cisco about it later they are talking
about the white emblem flash and Cisco
gives in the speech where he's like hey
wait a minute you know do we do the
white emblem because you saw it in the
past
or because we were already gonna do it
like they've already been wondering
about the idea of a time paradox like
are we doing this because we were always
destined to do it we're because we only
saw it in the past like what kind of
time loop are we setting off here so
throwing caution to the wind during
season two
Cisco comes up with the need to create a
new flash emblem like barriers gets
destroyed so he's like hey I had an idea
I made that white emblem that we saw
from that other version of Barry just
because it looks so cool so everyone's
like oh yeah you know he's getting
closer to the comic book version of the
costume but the color was still pretty
dull red so he got sucked into the Speed
Force during the course of season two
came back burned through a whole bunch
of versions of the costume in the color
was still dull red but the third version
of Barry in that season one finale that
tells him not to save his mother like
dude don't do it he has a bright red
costume so it's like hey wait a minute
is that is that like a future version of
the flash we're gonna see and then of
course the executive producers are like
oh we will go back to that moment so of
course everybody has an idea of
flashpoint even if you haven't read the
flashpoint comic book storyline you
might have seen the animated movie Barry
goes back saves his mother but it
destroys the timeline so when fixing
flashpoint Barry just has to come to
terms with the idea that his mother has
to die so he goes back allows that to
happen says his final goodbyes to his
mother and everything goes back to the
way it's supposed to be now we know on
the TV show that they're making a few
tweaks to the show so when Barry does
fix TV flashpoint a few things will
still be different but like we've
already seen pictures of Cisco in
episodes that they are still filming
right now he's wearing like his funny
t-shirts again so we know that Cisco
goes from being like Elon Musk douchebag
Cisco back to regular Cisco so like
Cisco is one of the things that we get
back when Barry fixes flashpoint but we
don't really know what else is going to
change likes avatar will still be the
big villain will still have the rival
the reverse flash will go off to legends
of tomorrow so the real question is is
that when this version of bit like
flashpoint berry goes back it has this
season one moment like we're looking at
season three Barry right here saying
don't save your mother
this is him trying to fix flashpoint
when does he get the bright red costume
is that going to happen in the
first couple of episodes is that a
result of Flashpoint
what's going on so you guys can let me
know like do you think they're gonna
brighten the costume a little before he
goes back to fix flashpoint there have
been times in the past when people have
thought that the costume looked brighter
and Grant Gustin has said well you know
sometimes they light it in a different
way so it looks brighter than it
actually is but it's the same color that
was in previous seasons but as you would
expect you know just part of the
excitement of a new season of TV is that
they refresh everything just make it
look a little bit newer a little bit
cooler so the flash costume will
continue to evolve season to season and
they always make minor tweaks - like
Cisco will embed technology in it so
like the suit does cool things even
though it might not look different like
when Captain Cold zapped him with his
cold gun Cisco had put like a little
heater in it so it heated the ice that's
an example of a really minor
modification so in addition to like
cosmetic changes season to season
they were like within each season there
will be like minor technology tweaks
just allowing Barry to do extra cool
things like Cisco will think of
something really cool like oh I'm just
gonna add this to the next flash emblem
that I built for Barry but a lot of that
will flow from the villains that Barry
faces like mirror master is gonna be a
new villain so it's gonna be really
exciting to see what new tweaks Cisco
develops based on the encounters that
Barry has and for those of you wondering
about mirror masters they did say that
they're not gonna do the mirror world
he's gonna be the Sam Scudder
mirror master so he'll just travel
between reflective surfaces they're not
gonna do like the whole alternate
universe thing just because that would
be kind of the way they portrayed earth
- but they could always do mirror world
in a future season but for now mirror
master is just gonna be jumping between
reflective surfaces so it's been a
little while since we got a new flash
trailer most of the footage that they've
shown off is just from the first couple
of episodes like the pre flashpoint
stuff so they can't really do a trailer
for stuff that's happening after that
because it'll be kind of spoilery so
what I think they'll do is they'll do
another flashpoint trailer with like a
few different things in it at least by
next week because in two weeks the
season is premiering if you didn't know
the flash is coming back in two weeks so
be prepared for that and as you may have
noticed YouTube has made a few changes
it's caused a few bugs in the system but
just
double check that you have alerts
enabled for my channel for uploads so
when I upload a new video like your
phone will tell you just so you don't
miss stuff and now you can click on the
links that I add at the end of videos so
like when I point to stuff and I'm like
hey click here watch this awesome
trailer you can actually click on that
now on your mobile phone but if you guys
have any trouble seeing videos or you
think you're missing stuff that I'm
posting just let me know in the comments
next video is gonna be Game of Thrones
spin-off this is some really exciting
stuff because agents of shield is
premiering so late tonight my episode 1
video for that will post tomorrow
morning but there's a new round of the
flash giveaway that's been going on all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'm still giving away flash blu-rays
until the season starts though it's
gonna be a lot of fun I'm really excited
about season 3 while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
all about killer frost in season 3 and
you can click here to watch that
Supergirl Superman trailer again thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight